Bruce says, do you do press releases for your Legion sites?
I've heard they can help new sites get a small amount of traction.
I don't know, just personally, okay?
And I can't even speak on that.
I've been part of groups, I've been pitched on doing press releases.
I know people have different opinions.
I have built my billion dollar seven figure $100,000 month agency,
literally doing the keyword, building my keyword list,
the way I teach you guys how to do it in the training.
Literally sitting down and it helps if you have a dual monitor,
but you don't have to sitting down when I didn't have a dual monitor,
I would print off a list of the keywords and I would be typing on my content.
I would start with five questions and I would literally go through
and I'd start writing and every time I would do a keyword,
I'd make a check mark or a strike and I would manually check
and make sure I included as many keywords as possible, but didn't overuse it.
And then when I got the dual screen, I would have the keywords over here
and the document over here and I would do the exact same thing,
except it was digitally.
And I have built a seven figure agency writing content, old school.